le niveau de violence est un niveau
inédit c'est un niveau inédit de
violence les rixes entre bandes
les jeux les gares les assassinats entre
ados parce qu'il faut mettre aussi des
mots sur sur les actes oui on se bat
avec des armes blanches avec des
couteaux maintenant avant c'était un
coup de poing blanc niveau c'est avec
des copines et 10 toutes les
statistiques le démontrent les cous de
tout ça d'abord le sentiment d'impunité
on sait qu'on ne risque rien qu'on ne
craint rien une absence de politique
pénale
vous avez vu tous les ministres qui sont
en charge de la sécurité ou la justice
sur votre plateau est ce qu'à un moment
donné vous avez entendu une politique
pénale très clair très ferme l'absence
de sanctions
un affaissement morale généralisée à un
effacement de toutes règles de civilité
donc on en arrive à quoi on en arrive à
ce que deux ados j'allais dire convoque
temps d'un guet-apens à une autre ado
pour la battre à mort il ajouté dans la
scène vivante sans que cela leur pose
une difficulté d'aucune sorte et qui
rentrent tranquillement chez eux et des
ados qui n'avaient pas de passé ni
judiciaires ni passé de délinquant
donc ça s'est banalisé aujourd'hui oui
la vie politique c'est de venir qui va
être le meilleur pour aller débattre
face à marine le pen
mais débattre à face à marine le pen on
l'a vu que monsieur darmanin c'est de
pouvoir l'affaiblir personnellement la
critique et la diaboliser mais loin de
ce que je cherche c'est pas d'affaiblir
madame le pen c'est affaiblir ses idées
c'est répond aux français qui ont envie
de voter pour elle pour expliquer que
ces propositions ne sont pas des
propositions viables dans l'intérêt de
la france et des français
mon combat il est là mon combat c'est
pas de dire oh là là qui va être le
meilleur pour dire madame le pen oh là
là elle est méchante elle est pas
républicaine elle et moi j'entendais
encore un membre de la majorité
présidentielle en disant oui plus
personne ne combat marine le pen mais
moi mon objectif politique et je vous
dis au delà même de mon appartenance aux
républicains mon objectif comme
citoyenne s'est pas de combattre madame
le pen c'est de combattre ses
propositions ses idées de comprendre
pourquoi une grande partie de plus en
plus important de français votent pour
elle
cv encore une fois on essaye de priver
les français d'élections pourquoi parce
que l'installation médiatique et
sondagière
du duel macro le pen ça un seul objectif
un seul objectif priver les français de
cette élection
ça veut dire quoi priver les français de
cette élection d'abord vous dire c'est
fait c'est fait oui mais oui la deuxième
chose c'est on est coeur aussi les
français de cela et je veux dire le
front républicain c'est pas un choix
politique le front républicain c'est pas
un choix de société
personne n'ose le dire je vous le dis le
front républicain qui s'effrite au fil
de l'eau depuis 2002 abandonné on va
bien avoir le le contrecoup de ce non
choix et cette privation d'élections
vis-à-vis des français et donc faut
faire très attention à ce que cette
installation médiatique ne se retourne
pas contre les français mais aussi
contre la classe politique et y compris
contre les journalistes vis-à-vis
desquels ils france est une très grande
défiance et vous savez